[Musik]
hey leute
wo geht die am liebsten draußen essen
ist vielleicht zeigt wo er einer der
kandidaten wo er gerne mal einen zopf
verspeist ich mag es ganz gerne also
zwischen mächtigen hamza und ich gerne
in meiner subway und was wir dann immer
wirklich immer kaufen ist ein cookie ist
nicht so es ist einfach so große kopie
und die haben sie kauft und ich sage was
[Musik]
ich möchte
naja so sind wir halt aber ist ja nicht
schlimm
jetzt wo ich weiß dass ich die auch zu
hause ganz einfach nachmachen kann muss
ich ja natürlich aber man kann halt auch
mal du musst jetzt haus verlassen um
software geschmack zu hause zu haben
ich weiß dass cookies backen überhaupt
keine kunst ist also cookies sind total
einfach zu machen aber ich habe die
perfekten make angaben gefunden die
perfekte konsistenz die art und weise
wie wir eben dieses glitschige
herbekommen dieses shui einfach richtig
lecker ich würde gerne auf die folter
spannen
ich zeige euch jetzt hier mal die
zutaten die wir benötigen die habt ihr
auch sicher fast alle zu hause also wir
benötigen zimmer warme butter außerdem
mehl und backpulver hier habe ich einen
braunen zucker oder rohrzucker
dann habe ich hier macadamia nuss
eventuelle prise salz white chocolate
chance und vanille extrakt und ich lüge
dich wenn im titel steht fünf minuten
subway pukki soll ich super kurz gesagt
ich bin stolz weil es ihm wirklich noch
fünf minuten zubereitungszeit und den
rest macht der backofen also das ist ja
nicht an eure arbeit versteht
wir sind crazy drauf ich bin jetzt die
zimmer waren butter in unserer
rührschüssel zusammen mit dem braunen
zucker und dann wird das ganze zwei
minuten an gemixt
[Musik]
nach den zwei bis drei minuten gibt ihr
das zeichen zu und rührt dass gerade so
unter bis es sich vermengt hat mit der
masse das dauert wirklich nur zehn
sekunden und mehr nicht jetzt nehmen wir
uns das mehl und das backpulver und 7
das in die masse hinein und auch das
wieder nur so lange verdünnt bis sie
sich gerade so verbunden hat jetzt habe
ich das vanille extrakt auch dazu
gegeben und wir haben ein anrecht festen
teig das ist genau richtig so und da
geben wir jetzt die macadamia nüsse rein
und aus meinem shop die weißen chocolate
chance und falls ihr die macadamia nüsse
schon gerüstet und gesalzen bekommt er
nimmt die gerne denn ihr wisst ja in
süßen sachen hebt salz immer so ein
bisschen den geschmack und falls ihr das
eben nicht gesalzen
daher bekommt das einfach eine prise
salz mit hinzugeben aber ich habe die
gesalzen daher brauche ich das in dem
fall ich
[Musik]
so ihr süßen jetzt schnappt ihr euch
euer backblech gibt da ein backpapier
oben drüber
und jetzt kommen die kopie ist auch
schon darauf tut man da eingefallen
nimmt immer sechs cookies für ein
backblech weil die werden ja noch ein
bisschen in die breite gehen im ofen und
daher wollen wir nicht dass er am ende
so ein riesen cookie auf dem backblech
haben und die alle zusammen kleben
obwohl genau ist eigentlich auch nicht
schlecht besetzt mir nicht mehr noch die
angefeuchteten händler und drückt jedoch
so ganz leicht flach und der rest
erledigt ja wirklich der offenen habe
ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 180 grad
ober unterhitze und jetzt aufgepasst
jeder backofen das anders jeder backofen
ist individuell
daher achtet drauf schaut nach zehn
minuten nach 11 und nach zwölf ganz
wichtig sie müssen noch richtig hell
sein der rand darf nur minimal goldbraun
sein denn alles andere ist schon zu
trocken denn wir wollen ja dass sie
bleiben und ich zeig euch gleich das
endergebnis
[Musik]
und fertig sind die white chalk
macadamia nach cookies wie von subway
und ihr dürft ihr gerne in die
kommentare schreiben welches rezept ich
als nächstes nach machen soll
gerne auch was herzhaftes man kann ja
auch mal die subway sachs nach machen
soll es geht auch super easy oder gute
idee
also wird es gibt natürlich tausende
varianten aber eine mögliche variante
ist mit thunfisch zum beispiel die aber
ich es proteste
ja sag ich ja das ist total easy also
gepackt das brot und dann könnt ihr das
beliebig
das ist machen soll da schreibt jeder
braucht noch mal so eine bestätigung von
euch und dann machen wir das ganze und
euch jetzt ganze freude beim nachbarn
schauten die video beschreibung dasteht
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben und dann
schickt mir bitte eure fotos oder postet
sie dass es noch besser mit dem hashtag
kiki sketchen auf instagram wir haben
das ist so ja ok alles klar ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel freude im nachbar
kennt dich dann tschüss
[Musik]